[Music]
the first thing is um my personal
experience of
in
suffering from seasonal affective
disorder
and that's not probably something that
you hear often in singapore because it's
so so sunny all the time which is
brilliant i loved it
yeah so we all know for the fact that
the sunlight is important
but we never truly
understand
the fact
and that's that's what happened to me
and the second frustration i had was how
we sort of start build our technological
nature
and distance ourselves from the nature
that's around us and to me as a person
the most beautiful thing that is is
always around us
actually i'm not i always think about
quantum physics superposition i'm
thinking rather about strategic scout
where
one object has two states
and that was an interesting thing i mean
it's kind of similar to it
and so i was thinking about a project
that's serious and absurd at the same
time i wanted to blood boundaries
between these two states and one one
thing that has two states so that's sort
of a representation of
what i want to do to realize from this
project
i'm talking about something so mundane
that everyone should be able to
understand
but not saying to the level of sort of
critical perspective of our sort of
humanities
and how we
how we how we do things and how we
create a technology is to to sort of
detach ourselves from the reality
and so that's critical so the
perspective of critical layers of my
project i think which is harder to sort
of understand
at first glance and if you're asking
in large
by large and
if design has a value to the larger
society
yes i do and the way we can solve some
problems
and like things like design design
thinking i think is um
it's a solvent problem solving sort of a
method that's been long utilized by
designers
but that's been sort of like
contextualized in the process so that
everyone can use
and that was pretty cool and
yeah it has value
you